right good evening everybody
welcome to the Development Committee
2013 November 2017
thanks to Sonia it's starting to warm up
a bit this before we get get going our
usual emergency evacuation announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building by the nearest available exit
of the chamber our assembly point won't
be in the public car park at the side of
the Civic suite please don't delay the
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return into the building
until given permission to do so by
account by council staff please also
note that this meeting won't be recorded
and if you've got a phone please put it
on silent thank you right
titan-1 apologies for absence have been
received from accounts Limerick under 1
2 at the same time actually council
America has been substituted by
councillor ward councillor Milan who has
been substituted by councillor Lucas
kale there any others ok thank you very
much and the three non-members attending
I can't see any number 4 minutes of the
meeting held on the 19th October 2017
happy for me to sign those as a
correction accurate record of that
meeting thank you
five declarations of interest item six
seven point one seven point two being
law Henry as a ward members area and
parish councillor thank you so take your
check again same items as ward
councillor and also as its county
council member for that division
Thank You NASA looks Kel Thank You
chairman non pecuniary interests as the
ward counsel Thank You members it's an
addendum that's been circulated has
everybody seen the addendum and had a
chance to write okay we've just received
it councillor Griffin can you make sure
that at the end you've had proper time
to taking all the information concerned
before you come to your decision on a
particular item thank you
so item number six land to the west of
Oak Road and north of horn Road Rochford
mr strannix is going to take this one
thank you
Thank You chairman this application is
to the northern side of Hall Road this
photograph usually used usefully shows
the development that's in progress but
we're background members will recall
that the site was formerly Greenbelt and
was released in your allocations plan in
2014 it was subsequently granted
outlined planning permission for 600
dwellings that's taking the site up to
the outer boundaries of the iron well
lane and slightly further to the west
and then there was two applications for
reserve master caster Newport I think
we've just been started at just about a
minute so can I just check you've seen
the addendum on this one right okay just
don't want to do it make sure you've got
the opportunity to take part in this
we've only just started so yeah you're
just in the nick of time so just say to
help members to orientate where the site
is anyone perhaps not quite familiar
with it so this site was allocated from
the Greenbelt it received outlined plan
admission then to large chunks of
reserved matters the first one which is
largely under construction here which
was for 293 dwellings and then later on
a further remainder of the site for 307
Wellings in 2016 if we can jump to the
character area
this plan don't worry too much members
about what you see underneath the sole
purpose of just reminding you of this is
that the development itself rather and
have a monotony of say 600 houses
looking the same it was subject to
controls by way of definition of
character areas with higher densities in
the middle a relationship to the spine
Road that goes through the site the
entrance details and then the outer
limits of the site as you bled into the
countryside just to remind members that
there was a character approach to this
this development so although the house
types are common in a lot of places
throughout it their treatment and their
relationship to each other are different
now members with a keen eye will see the
plots that concern us are up here
there's a better plan to come but you'll
see that relates to this bit here than
these up here if we can jump to thee
what I've called the red and purple
plots please Rob this plan if we can
zoom in on this centre if that's
possible members will see that this
basically is an application to uplift
the overall 620 by 20 units it actually
only affects that second of the reserved
matters application which usefully is
shown in a more darker outline this is
the earlier phase of reserved matters
which is under construction but if
members can see though we're we're
looking at the purple plots being the
proximate indication of where the new
dwellings the new 22 Elling czar being
sited in order to fit them in the
applicant has had to remodel the
remainder of all the areas that you see
red and I'll take you through plans to
show you two that you'll see it affects
what's already been granted plan of
mission they front existing roads that
are already laid out and obviously the
school site is reserved and not part of
this at the end there as well as the
open spaces beyond and the perimeter
open spaces around the site as well as
in inside it so the bits that concern us
tonight chairmen are those that are
outlined in red and basically what it
does is it takes out the larger houses
to 5 bedroom and 28 four-bedroom houses
in those areas edge rate and it brings
in for one-bedroom apartments up here
which we're seeing better detail in a
moment
and 17 two bedroom houses and 29
three-bedroom houses and there's a plan
to come but it will show you that
because there's 20 extra dwellings seven
of those will be affordable which will
be located up in this end because your
policy requires for that increasing
number to have a 35% increase in
affordable an affordable provision if we
can jump to our four please rob sorry
just for we leave that that helps you
better showing just the context of where
the plots are in relation to to the
development if we can jump to o4 please
rob and the first slide now this one the
applicant has usefully shown this is
what was approved to this part of the
scheme which was seven detached houses
and you'll see it's been revised to nine
houses by introducing a pair of semies
which are the two-bedroom properties and
also putting the the houses in a
terraced link group so that they're
they're pushed up which gives the space
but it still maintains the spaciousness
and the architecture that's part of
those character areas that I showed
earlier on in your report your seek
reference to the semi-detached being on
a narrow frontage went particularly when
you're in filling in existing streets
you require a frontage of some 15 meters
these are on 13 meter frontages but
you'll see because of the car parking
spaces either side there is plenty of
side space these two dwellings here two
bedrooms so they only require 50 square
metres of garden area but they have an
adequate setting that does not
compromise those characters that I
showed you on the big colored plan and
layout if we can jump to two please Rob
similarly in this second side you'll see
where the applicant has shown what was
approved on this part of the site which
was three detached and a pair of
semi-detached houses and that's been
revised with seven in the arrangement
shown it's now part of the character of
the spine road where the the bus route
would follow through and you'll see his
tree-lined Avenue and the exterior walls
here would be finished in yet and red
and yellow light broth brick with
weather boarding and plain tiles as they
make a transition
from the other areas the detached house
at plot 47 which is this one on the end
is the one that you're see has a
shortfall of three square meters and
though I'll help you with that in a
moment
hopefully members will see at least on
this plan that that garden spaces is
usable which is officer's point in the
recommendation if we could jump to three
please rob again is same format this is
what was approved in the reserve matters
that council has already granted consent
for and in that revision they've again
adapted it to put in from what was six
detached houses to two detached two
pairs of semi and a terrorists of three
so uplifting this small area by three
were small in the context of the overall
site by three extra dwellings but again
you'll see there's adequate isolation
spaces and the character is not
compromised if we could jump to four
please Rob here we see again an area
there where there was eight detached
houses and that's become a greater mix
of dwellings this is now moving into
that northern character area onto as a
development bleeds out towards the open
space on the edge of the site and onto
our emerald lime this has become 14
houses by a guy in a mix of
semi-detached and and still detached
dwellings in that mix in the report
officers have highlighted to members
that these two plots here there are only
a meter apart normally we would like to
see a gap of 2 meters wall-to-wall but
again in this setting around this tight
courtyard here with semi-detached
buildings obviously in this case
officers do not see that there is any
demonstrably harm by that slight
shortfall inside isolation spaces if we
could jump to the next one please Rob in
this fifths slide the applicant again is
up to the numbers there was a detached
garage on this plot that has become a
dwelling through through moving around
and shuffling the sizes of the dwellings
and there is also where we have the
the situation where buildings have
become semi-detached again saving on on
plot frontages if we can see the I think
it should be the last one is it Rob oh
yes this one the second but last again
the same idea this is where the
applicants have introduced the it's a
block of four two-up two-down flats but
you'll see these blue circles mean the
affordable element and there's a plan
I'm going to show you in a second which
shows you the clustering but the same
approach taking out larger properties
and put in smaller ones in in the same
area and if we can see the last one
please Rob in this position members will
see here there was a detached and a pair
of semi-detached what the applicant has
done because the affordable housing
requirements is for smaller particularly
two-bedroom houses they've still got
three dwellings in this location but
they're smaller and they're produced in
a terraced format if we could jump to oh
that's right the affordable housing
members will remember from the previous
applications that the affordable housing
is clustered there in the areas where
you see blue and the sites that are
before you tonight are in the red
outline and you'll see where the
affordable housing provision is proposed
it joins that cluster there are joining
the school site which isn't part of this
scheme still part of the overall
development but I think there's been
lots of rumors about these proposed
extra houses are on the site of the
school and you can clearly see that they
are part of remodeling what you've
already approved not on the school site
because rumours saying the school isn't
gonna happen or whatever the school so
it remains there as hopefully members
can clearly see now in terms of the
broad density increase members can see
that 20 extra dwellings this is the
collection of the sites that you've got
before you now with the landscaping
details show officers take a view that
the 20 extra tellings over the six
hundred and six hundred and the broad
proportions of the site etc doesn't have
a meaningful impact on the overall
density of the scheme it also provides
for smaller household to meet demands
that we have through our market
assessment so officers are supportive in
principle of that members will see on
the report that
the guards are drainage the lead local
flood authority just Rifai it requires
some extra technical details to do with
how the extra surface areas will be met
within the system the applicant has
provided as you'll see in your report an
assessment or an addendum to the
assessment that was done but before
signing that off in its entirety the
lead flood authority have just asked
from extra details which office is a
Content can be dealt with by condition
we have yesterday received now a highway
view on this scheme you'll notice that
wasn't in the report before you and the
highway authorities have no objection to
this and the layout members will have
seen from the previous drawing so that
the Front's the existing layout and the
car parking areas are provided to your
standard is just that you'll see in the
recommendation there's an uplift to the
legal agreement on certain points and
the Highway Authority asked that the bus
contribution be increased
proportionately to do with the number of
dwellings that are being increased now
from table 1 of your report on page six
point two three members will see that
four of the 43 plots affected are below
the minimum standard sought by the
council I think the worst one is 12
square metres and I pointed that one out
to you whilst we was looking at the
slides in detail the role of guard
nearest and primarily relates to
infilling to try and get the balance
right between amenity space where you're
squeezing dwellings perhaps amongst
existing layouts whereas in this case
it's a brand-new layout and members will
recall that the layout previously on
this site had a few shortfall in spaces
I think as half a dozen across the
remaining spaces members may also recall
that when we dealt with the application
or one of the applications at the
christmas-tree farm site that issue was
challenged by members we went into an
appeal and we subsequently lost that
appeal where the inspector felt that
whilst it was perhaps regrettable that
the garden spaces weren't quite to the
size as it was part of a wider scheme
and liked this scheme had access to
nearby areas of public open space which
you saw in the big layout skirt the site
and also as a couple of small squares in
the development itself that was good
enough to to accept the shortfall so in
these circumstances
offers offices see a direct comparison
to that appeal decision and on this
occasion do not feel it amounts to a
defensible reason for refusal
similarly on table two you'll see the
analysis against the space standards now
all of the house types that are used are
short to a minor why some on just the
storage and cupboard space others on the
gross you'll see it's not a substantial
shortfall but the point here is that
those house types have already been
approved in the layouts they're already
being built so it's very difficult to
demonstrate a harm caused by that
shortfall other than just merely for
standards sake we have this policy DM 4
that's been superseded by the national
standard and the shortfall all that
would do would just be trying to enforce
that as a rigid standard which I'm not
sure the government the Inspectorate
would support us those house types
already precedented in the layouts that
have been approved now in terms of
overall infrastructure I make the point
earlier about the the legal agreement if
you see at paragraph three point three
to the officer report the outline
permission is on page six point three
the outline permission was subject to a
number of terms for the legal agreement
now a lot of these have been provided
like the round about hunts or haul road
other Junction improvements at Sutton
Road and the amber lynn junctions
they're so physical things that have
already been provided this this all
uplift cannot cannot meet because that's
already been done but what officers and
the applicants feel that where the
numbers are in or in question such as
the the bus subsidy education places
things like that their national health
contributions that were just money into
a broader pot to go into those services
these right and proper that this scheme
which is a standalone full application
should contribute like the outline
before it to that uplift and therefore
chairman the recommendation reflects
that before I get to that just on the
addendum members will see that there's a
clarification to paragraph five point
two of
the officer report hopefully better
setting out for members the situation
with land supply and also comments from
South M Borough Council who who point
out to members naturally that the
education contributions is a matter for
Essex County Council so the
recommendation chairman is approval
subject to the heads of terms for the
proposed legal agreement set out in the
recommendation and to those conditions
set out in the report thank you I have a
speaker on this one mr. Michael Smith
Thank You Jay and on behalf of Bellway
homes thank you for the opportunity to
address the committee this evening mr.
Strang Susan described the scheme in
great detail therefore I don't intend to
repeat what he's already said instead I
just like to emphasize the proposal is
attended to address the change in demand
for new homes and does not seek to
dilute the quality of the approved
scheme feedback from the sales teams at
Bellway homes and Ashbury homes is that
potential customers have shown greater
interest than as anticipated for the two
and three-bedroom houses
whereas demand for the 4-bedroom houses
has been limited rearranging the
approved layer in small areas of the
site has allowed us to take out some
larger properties and place from small
homes for private sale and a mixture of
houses and apartments as affordable
housing the developers are expecting
that the provision of smaller houses
will better match the demand speeding up
the rate of sales construction and
delivery of the new homes the outline
permissions sought to ensure that the
whole development appears as a single
and coherent scheme but also allowed
individual streets and spaces to create
a sense of place and to define the
character of each neighborhood the
proposed changes maintain the character
for the areas in which they are located
an entry plan has been designed in
accordance with the existing design
brief and public rome design strategy
it's intended that the uplifter 20 new
homes will be a continuation of the
approved scheme and that when
construction was complete it will not be
possible to see where the changes have
been made the revised scheme has been
designed to avoid additional impacts
wherever possible and the change to the
mix of accommodation means that the
scheme for 620 dwellings includes just
three more bedrooms than the approved
layout for 600 times
there is also a small increase in the
total floor area but it's balanced by
the small reduction in the number of
habitable rooms technical issues have
also been taken into account
we know changes needed to the approved
road layout and the total amount of hard
servicing left broadly unchanged which
means that the approved sustainable
drainage system does not need to be
revised in addition the officer how it
works have already been constructed as
mr. drank said with capacity to
accommodate twenty more homes and
financial contributions secured is
planning obligations will be increased
on a proportional basis it's important
to note the proposed uplift does not
require any alterations to the
strategies for the delivery of the
school site funding of primary and
secondary schools subsidy for the bus
service that will run through the sites
and provision of health care within the
town the parishioner fordable housing is
increased to match the creation of the
extra homes for private sale in line
with the mix sought by the council's
housing team and maintaining the level
of provision at 35 percent of the total
number of new homes to conclude the
proposed changes are intended to address
the current mismatch between supply and
demand for new homes at the site and
care has been taken to ensure that the
high quality scheme is not diluted by
swapping larger houses for smaller
properties the character of the
site-wide development will not be
altered and the scheme has been designed
to avoid negative impacts and will be
accompanied by an increase in the
funding obligations that have already
been secured as such I trust you will
find the proposed very plan to be
acceptable and that you will concur with
the case officer recommendation and
resolve to approve the abrogation okay
members I'm suspecting that the
discussions around this one were well
drawn out and tested quite some time ago
that's the scepter thank you chair just
a couple of questions if I may with
regards to the Terrace properties what
is the where is the allocation for the
Center buildings for the bin stores
and with regards to the additional
properties that will be for social
housing law the seven properties will
watch for District Council have the
nomination rights a really a curiosity
on the attendant it comments on Southend
Borough Council commenting on the school
from the school development manager I
don't quite understand why he would be
making a comment from Southie children a
mobile on these days chairman the issue
from south ember accounts were largely
came out and the negotiations
behind-the-scenes going on with the
legal agreement about signatories to the
agreement cuz South end were signatories
to the original outline because some of
those highway works are mentioned are in
South in borough because of the impact
of the scheme on the road network which
doesn't recognize local authority
boundaries the impact of traffic is
where it is hopefully finding a refuge
strategy and I've Rob can zoom in on
that but the the applicants have thought
that this we could nothing gets into
some Terrace units perhaps this one
where you see they're linked terraced
the idea is the bins are stored and I
can get down to the corner Rob that's it
that one there members might be able to
see it better than me but hopefully they
see the bins are stored in the garden
and then there's collection points
whoops
Street side and I think they go out
through that way so that middle one goes
out through that door or that path I
can't quite see that one there must be
away somewhere gate there probably but
it's my understanding and having seen
the plans in detail rather than move me
Nick turned that it does comply the the
application was shown to the council's a
team and they didn't well they didn't
respond to the reply so I assume they
have not got strong objections to it but
that typically that's the arrangement I
mean that we've got a plan of this for
all the plots but hopefully that
satisfies members question on there and
in terms of nomination rights that is
correct that
there is a the element of affordable
housing the 35% that is with a housing
provider that the council has first
choice from our lists to nominate people
to that there are rumors around of other
authorities and agencies buying houses
on the open market causing rumors that
other people have bought and they're not
from this district but that is a matter
between the applicant who they choose to
sell their houses to but I can confirm
to members that the blue ones that you
saw on the affordable housing plan the
35% of the what is now the 620 they
would be under the the partner that
would have nomination rights from this
council
let's yell with regards to the food
storage I'm still not clear taking the
two center
Chim Chim and they would come through
follow the the dotted line they would go
through the garage down there driving
and then out to the collection points
which are shown in blue there okay Thank
You members Thank You chairman the
answer to that question and a curious
question as to are these guarantees
extra wide to accommodate the
transportation of the bins to past room
when there's a parked vehicle in there I
think chairman the standard doesn't
account for those eventualities I mean
what what who do if we have to move bins
or any lawn mowers out the garden into
the front or whatever we normally move
our cars or we move things around I can
tell you that the garages are to your
preferred standard the three meters wide
by the 7 meters deep so you know you
could Park it over if you didn't want to
take the car out but whether you get a
been passed that's another matter but
the whole idea is that these are
relatively secure because of the built
frontages and then access is possible
through the garage link to to street
side once a week for the collections
chair final
Thank You chairman hmm so there's no
other alternative access to the rear
garden areas on those particular
properties and apart from through the
garage I'm considering four safety
aspects Jim I'm not sure I understand
the point about the safety but the this
is one arrangement there are other
arrangements with I don't know if we can
see the affordable housing block but
you'll see that those Gardens have an
alleyway so I think the applicant is
thought about this and there's one type
of solution that they've thought of and
there are others I know there is
somewhere in those those 43 plots there
are some with back alleyways but I'd
probably have to pore over the plans to
pick them out to you I don't know if we
can see some can we go up to the other
end near the school site Rob there might
be some there if we can zoom in on this
part
- come come down come down a bit and
across
I know I've seen alleyways somewhere
chairman but I can't memorize which
plots they were but generally hopefully
members are see the collection points
are curbside and they're convenient to
the houses which i think is the ambition
broadly just not try get caught up in
too much small detail remembering that
everything that we're seeing there in
terms of style of house is already
approved elsewhere in the plots that's
why the thing Council Newport Thank You
chairman house house the additional
visitors parking catered for in the
scheme chairman highways were very
particular with this scheme because if
it's Town Center location and the
proximity to the train station they did
not favor visits a provision to be
provided what they anticipated is if you
provide all the labors on the street
that they will be blocked by commuters
and then what they would have to get
into is residents parking only permit
schemes
controls and things like this and they
said let's plan that out it's near that
Rochford town center so some plots they
have perhaps an extra space within the
plot but there isn't a hundred percent
visitor provision throughout the estate
because they did not want the road to
become a car park for commuters specific
answer that's yeah come back on that
um I think counselor Steptoe mentioned
Terrace housings and work so where was
the parking allocation for terraced
housing it's in front of them I mean
hopefully if we can zoom in on these you
see a lot of these terraces are sorta
like detached link formats almost but
you'll see garages and then you'll see
the parking space in front of them I'm
not aware of any shortfall on the plots
the residents themselves and they are
provided as I said at your preferred
size so they're bigger than than what's
gone on before other than in the new
escapes final question counselor hook
why thank you German I noticed in the
report that mentioned about adjustments
to the money s106 money agreements
because of the increasing numbers but
it's a it doesn't give any actual
amounts so is it possible you can
actually give us it in pounds and pence
please thank you
I deliberately avoided that chairman
because the amounts have changed and I
wanted to express that it was 26
hundredths of whatever the mountain was
final to the other agreements so I think
just as a guide that the National Health
contribution I'm looking for the
applicant to nod I think it's three
hundred eighty three thousand the
National Health yes so it would be
whatever 26 hundreds of is of three
hundred eighty three thousand that would
go to the NHS by way of an example and
there's similar contributions to the
education Authority or take that amount
divided by six hundred then twenty of
those go towards the education Authority
and there is also a bus subsidy that's
per dwelling so that cash amount divided
by six hundred twenty of them added to
the figure so we will work out those
those amounts it's index-linked so that
as time progresses and until they get
the triggers and the implementations
then the money would go up as an amount
because it's obviously proportion
to the increase in price index etc
hopefully that helps gym members there's
a recommendation for approval printed on
six point three six going on for a few
pages those members in favor of the
approval please indicate those against
and kill that item is carried we might
be having a bit of an IT issue by the
sound of it brewing
right members an unfortunate up the
computer update is requiring the system
to reboot which is probably about five
minutes worth so I shall call you up
adjourn and call you back that are
exactly 10 past please sorry about that
this application relates to the king's
head public house in the center of
Rochford the building is located within
the town center Rochford and as a
frontage looking towards a Market Square
[Music]
the building is great to list it and
there's also a tandem application for
consideration tonight for a listed
building descent the building has been
empty for approximately eighteen months
to two years members may recall a
previous application in August for an
application for twelve bed seats and one
small shop unit which was refused on the
grounds that the proposed loss of the
ground-floor commercial premises the
public house within this important town
center location would have an adverse
impact on the commercial by Talty of
watch for town center the tandem
application for listed building said it
was approved by members members may also
recall an application by the same
developer at 22 South Street which was
approved in February to convert vacant
offices into twelve bed suits this was
also a listed building the residential
use of that building has documented this
proposal mostly involves internal
conversion worth to subdivide the
existing rooms externally the
alterations are not considered
significant with no alterations to the
front and limited alterations to the
rear
[Music]
the front part of the ground-floor would
be converted into three shop units which
would utilize existing two entrances to
the building one of these entrances
would also provide access for open floor
bed sits the rear part of the building
would contained for bed suits the shop
units would have floor spaces of sixteen
point eight meters squared 19 meters
squared and 20 point 15 meter squared
the two largest units could be altered
to provide one unit if required the
council's economic development team
considered the inclusion of these
commercial units would have a positive
impact on the vitality of the Watford
town center having objected to the
previous application a new access will
be provided to the rear and a doorway
would be formed into bedsit for through
the enlargement of an existing window
opening within the courtyard ador'd up
possibly formed it of bed set three the
first floor would be converted two to
seven bed suits
there will be mild external alterations
to the rear corner providing for a fire
escape access with stairs and the door
opening to bed sir 11 through the
enlargement of an existing window
opening all bed sets would include an
ensuite shower room allowing for
independent living the bed sets would
vary in size between eleven point eight
eight meter squared and twenty-three
point three one meter squared
officers considered that proposal would
be cordis with national and local
planning policy and the inclusion of
three shop units overcomes the previous
reason for refusal the recommendation to
members is for approval
that's not really thank you German so
the Parish Council has a number of
concerns regarding this application we
have concerns over the number and size
of beds it's in light of the three
retail units being added or the the the
additional two and only one beds it lost
has the quality of the living area in
these beds it's now been reduced and is
this not over developed over development
we have concerns over the number and
size of retail units the feasibility of
them being let in the current climate
seen in Rockford Square and question
whether a single large unit might entice
a business that could serve Rochford
demographic during both daytime and into
evenings we have concerns over the
current structure of the building
especially the top story we would need
or want cast-iron guarantees that this
cannot represent a safety risk or better
that the structure has been
substantially improved Grenville has
shown when it comes to people safety the
bare minimum is not enough regarding the
proposed development itself there seems
to be aspects of some alterations and
internal petition walls that do not
appear to be in keeping with this being
a listed building we observe that there
has seemingly been a precedent already
set on refusal of change of commercial
properties to residential in the town
square and along West Street in recent
applications we have a couple of
specific questions regarding this
application what are the arrangements
for bin storage and waste management and
what is it what is the expected impact
on the town center for car parking of
the bed sits visitors of those residents
and the retail units and finally we
would have liked to have seen further
information on the following two areas
we would like to see a safety report on
the impact of this change of use in the
area before further discussions are made
and we would like to see a feasibility
report on the loss of this commercial
property in the town should the smaller
retail units be unsuccessfully let
before further decisions are made thank
you
mr. Walker thinks is the agent
gleave mr. chairman members the king's
head public house was purchased by my
client for the a commercial agent Aten
for the owners Shepherd NIEM who have a
large number of public heresies in the
survey of England the pub closed in
September of 2015 and has been empty
ever since Shepherd lien being a very
experienced pub chain regretfully found
that the pole use of King's Head was no
longer viable as a public house and
business and I understand had been
suffering as a business for a period of
time before its closure the building
fabric is deteriorating sorry from jump
the Paula Harrison business and I
understand Dan had been so maligned he's
over there so at the building fabric is
deteriorating and has been broken into
broken into twice and I'm of there I am
aware wolf the King's Head was great to
list it in 1959 the internal of the
building has had a lot of internal
changes and fitting out within the
original building also extensive
structural repair work carried out
within the second floor loft area which
cannot be reused the proposed is to
refurbish and fit out the existing
building including alterations to
provide three self-contained small shop
units to the front of the building
facing out onto the market square where
Street together with 11 bit bed suits
the first the front facade of the
building would not change retaining the
various moldings around doors windows
together with the timber sash windows
the existing dude always being retained
the sellers will be retained in their
current form no words planned in these
areas access to the residential
accommodation will be from Westar II
front of the building and from backline
the rear as has been rebuilt and
improved and would provide an area for
refuse bins and cycle story
the building if converted to commercial
use and residential accommodations
provide the use it was originally built
for the shop units will be suitable for
small retailers and ideal for new
startup businesses shops businesses shop
units one and two could be joined to
improve and provide one larger unit
there is no specific use for each shop
at present the shots would have a
positive impact in the town centre he's
understood that there is a real need for
startup businesses the council's local
development plan and seek to protect and
increase retail focus on the district
town centers the 11 multi occupied
occupancy flats are located to the rear
of the ground-floor and to the first
floor the previous as previously stated
access to the flats will be from West
Street and from back line the rear
access provided a new fire escape refuse
bin storage for the flats and cycle
storage there is no plan being provided
and therefore no traffic congestion
public transport links local to the site
are good the the this providing of a
small affordable accommodation listed
building approval was previously granted
following consultations with the council
and it is kind of capsule conservation
officer the building's works from be
carried out to the building regulation
standards and taken into account for
detection and comm compartment ation and
escape the building currently falls
short of the current fire regulation
standards and therefore works will
improve and meet the current fire
detection with escape and protection for
commercial and residential use to go yet
the building as it stands to be subject
to vandalism and arson
thank you very much next speaker is mr.
poorly Thank You Chet um my name is
Laurence Pauly I'm here to represent
some of the many local residents who are
concerned about this proposed
development as evidenced by the negative
responses both to this application and
the refused application earlier this
year I want to touch on three points the
impact of the proposal on the commercial
viability of the town center the
suitability of the development for any
future tenants and the impacts on the
quality of life for local residents on
the first point the committee will be
aware that a similar proposal for this
site was rejected earlier this year on
the grounds that were damaged the
vitality of the town center contrary to
policy 3 of the town cent action plan
the planning officer has argued a
revised proposal which makes provision
for free shop units instead of one
overcomes is concerned I do not agree
with this assessment the revised
proposal still represents a significant
loss of commercial space with a large
proportion of ground-floor
formerly part of the Kings Head pub
converted to four bedsit units this both
represented detrimental impact on the
viability of the center and does not
provide a return as the view slightly
still contribute to the overall offer of
the area as such it continues to
contravene policy free of the town
center action plan I know the economic
development of his argument the proposed
shop units could provide beneficial
space for startups I don't disagree with
the principal but then it's surely
appropriate to retain the entire ground
floor for commercial use allowing for a
genuine hub for small businesses in a
prominent historic location there should
be much more in keeping with the
council's vision for the Town Center
building on its heritage and seeking to
attract small retailers such as arts and
craft specialists
by contrast the current proposal as set
out in the objection by David Curtis
would set an alarming precedent for the
hollowing out the town center making it
harder to refuse similar applications
for future vacant units such as the
Bacchus Bank building currently these
long-term effects can be hugely damaging
for the town
there are even issues with the free
propose shop units which appear to like
directory access and share hallways with
other shop units or residential
entrances this is not looking likely to
be attractive to future retail tenants
moving to the level of amenity provided
to the future residents of the bed suits
I draw the committee's attention to
policy D and 35 of the local development
framework development management plans
states are the upper floors of shops and
commercial premises and town centers can
be used for residential purposes however
it states Commission will be granted
where appropriate to ensure that
accommodation is self contained and that
such accommodation provides a
satisfactory standard of residential
convenience and amenity turning to the
plans it appears that method 6 5 and 6
on the first floor are not
self-contained sharing a bar from access
by a common hallway in addition the
plans do not appear to include any
laundry or utility facilities in
contrast to the proposal from the same
applicant which was granted in relation
to 22 South Street there will clearly be
space in the building to do all these
issues although it would likely require
a reduction in the number of renter
tracking bedrooms therefore I believe
the proposals it stands contravenes
policy dim 55 and I'd also committed to
lay down a marker that Rochford
particularly in such a prominent
location can and should aim higher than
providing these minimal living
conditions finally on the impact on the
local residents I'm very aware of the
pressures on local councils to provide
housing units including by increasing
density now in town center areas however
I seems to recall that a number of
developments of flats and bed sets have
even been completed or are in progress
in the immediate vicinity these include
the HTML 22 South Street the conversion
of the old delivery office and East
Street the conversion of a shop unit of
North Street and proposed new flats on
South Street
this pattern of development will never
to be lead to pressures on
infrastructure and our concern there
seems to be no attempt to address the
cumulative impact I echo the concerns of
residents who have raised these issues
in their objections and I'd welcome for
example a child here from local NHS
providers and schools there are also the
gist of our concerns about potential
issues that can come with increased HMO
density in an area including a relation
to fear of crime here I'll draw the
committee's attention to Essex Police is
comment on the application earlier for
an 18-month 22 South Street they noted
that the National Planning policy
framework paragraph 69 seeks to promote
a residential environment in which a
fear of crime does not undermine quality
of life or community cohesion they noted
the potential adverse consequences
associated with HMOs and they requested
that the council gave consideration
towards refusing that development which
didn't happen while I'd not commented on
this proposal I see no reason why the
same reasoning would not play yeah and I
believe if they view should be sought
it's already eminently clear in any case
from consultation responses the develop
would lead to increased fear of crime in
town center causing distress to
residents and further undermining the
vitality and attractiveness of the area
30 seconds
no problem wrapping up in summary I
believe the proposals wholly
inappropriate and unacceptable from
policy perspective it was detract from
the commercial viability of the town
center it offers a poor standards of
amenity to potential residents it would
intensify pressures on local services
and risk causing detriment to the
existing population as such Allison the
application be refused
thank you thank you
that's the Steptoe is naked
screwby Thank You Jay I've got some
questions are really around the
commercial aspects of the property with
regards to the three units has a
feasibility study been done to see what
their potential rentable value is in
terms of being able to rent them out on
the drawing they're the two shops on the
left of the drawing there if a tenant
wanted to a larger premises would that
be possible to make that into one and I
have been concerned about the the third
commercial unit there because their
access through there is also access to
properties I'm not sure if it's on the
first floor on the second floor if there
was a business going in there and you've
got people just wandering in and out
there the security on that property
would be perhaps questionable what
arrangements have been put in place to
actually stop and mitigate any issues
around that
thank you sir Williams Thank You
chairman yeah as councillor stepped a
point say I have serious concerns
regarding the viability of these
commercial units I know that we need
desperately we need more and more
emergency accommodation and houses of
occupancy
I'm not sure that this is the right
place I'm not sure this has been through
thought through enough and I do have
serious concerns regarding this HMS
house generally have a very transient
[Music]
nature they're transient the people that
are living in a minute and I'm concerned
that the rot should itself will not be
getting a building a nice community for
the Russians Square and and to go to the
future with this and yeah thank you
I do have these concerns thank you
thank you Jack to take those couple of
questions on the feasibility of the
units and the security aspect yeah well
we haven't had a feasibility study for
the retinal values for it
shop units one and two to the larger two
units
they've got petition Wars between them
which can be removed to create a larger
shop unit if required in order to save
the frontage of the existing building
the existing frontage is unchanged that
the existing entries to the building's
unchanged but there is a requirement to
access the old bull flats and officers
don't consider there'll be an extreme
there's going to be sufficient conflict
between the uses of the beat places
upstairs and the occupants of the shop
to have any cause for the concern
yeah concern about poverty my concern is
it's no parking spaces so I could see
the people that stay there
reduce the parking spaces where people
gonna shop in the shop so that's my one
concern it's about the parking and I do
think that there's too many this could
be too many beds it's there as well um
could I ask how many vacant commercial
premises of this sort there are we much
for Town Center because my concern is
that if we end up over supplying this
rather than have an empty pub we'll just
have a load of empty office space
thanks that's the mountain thank you
I've been trying to for somebody's not I
have no internet access on my iPad at
the moment but the the last speaker made
reference to policy I believe it was dim
34 is that correct and and I just want
clarification over that regarding the
the bed sits upstairs in the communal
bathroom okay cast award Thank You
chairman I'm on a wee bit amazed with
regard to the shops that are going in
there and why it was never considered
viable that you could still have those
bed seats but you could still actually
retain a going public house within that
same area
and I'm very disappointed that this
alternative has not been taken forward
by Shepherd name and I'm also concerned
with regard to the number of vacant shop
premises in Rockford and it kind of
disappoints me to say more shock present
premises coming on when existing shop
premises are not being completed thank
you Thank You chairman yes you know I'm
very concerned in relation to the fact
that there is no provision for any car
parking doesn't seem to be any provision
for that whatsoever and bearing in mind
the number of dwellings or bed sits
within within this being 11 it's quite a
considerable number of no provision we
are we assuming that none of these
people who were largely talked to by
this will have any vehicles at all I
think I just must mention this is a town
center location with significant amounts
of public parking available close by and
a railway station well served by bus
routes we've exercised this argument on
a number of occasions around Braley and
Rochford and we've clearly had it
demonstrated that providing parking in
town center locations is not required
cancer Steptoe you wanted to come back
yes thanks chair I think the question
when I asked about the feasibility of
the units wasn't on the value or what
they could be rented for was what the
potential that they could be rented out
my follow-up question to that is if it
is this committee is a mind to pass the
application and the units can't be
rented out does the applicant have to
come back to us to do anything further
with those particularly units before
they could be converted into other flats
or whatever change of years application
I have to be I just want a clarification
can we come back on those other answers
around vacant premises and the the DM
policy please don't have a number of
limo vacant units of what his tone sent
at the moment but I do believe there are
a few vacant units in terms of the
parking arrangements the standard for a
public house is one space per five
square meters of floor space for a
building of this size if it was to
remain as a public house members would
require a lot of parking space for this
the number of spaces for residential use
of the property is much lesser than what
we require for a public house the
customers who will go to a public house
driving a car to the site or parking in
the district would be Muslim would
result in more traffic movements in
parking in the area to me residential
use of the site in terms of policy DM 35
the first floor will have to two
separate entrances
those intentions from back lane in the
rear left hand corner of the fire exit
to best at 11:00 and loss without
divides for fire sit egress from me
first floor as well the rest of it can
be accessed through the front through by
the existing shop units or by the
prepared shop units and these will be
returned to the independent access there
was the other question about the shared
facility bathroom was it yeah the on the
first floor there's two bedrooms or two
baths this which will share a bathroom
that's it's number five basic number six
okay accounts the mountain that was your
point in particular correct as we heard
referenced earlier that that contravenes
the put the policy if I'm a policy DM
thirty five deals with situations when
we find commercial shops that used to
have what they called the living over
the shop shopkeeper used to live
upstairs so in order to get to the
upstairs flat if they become separate
entities not in the same ownership it
requires an independent access so so in
in dealing with applications for
upstairs flats or accommodation the idea
was that it should have an independent
access that the dwellers shouldn't have
to walk through the shop or the
hairdresser's or whatever it is in order
to go upstairs to where they live now
this scheme achieves that it's got an
entrance which one of the shops leads
off but it's also got an entrance at the
back so so that the the residential
dwellers in the bed seats would not have
to walk through the shop premises to get
to where they live
yeah I'd come back again thank you that
that's not in question it was the
communal yeah yeah
as far as sort of bed set accommodation
compared to self-contained units of
concern they're different sort of
underused class in the way they're
monitored so bed sets can have share
facilities where a self-contained flats
don't so in this case it's HR moment and
a shared facility here which means there
could be shared bathrooms in that so
there is the level of compliance because
the description I remembers some unease
however there is a recommendation for
approval printed on page 7.15 with some
with the relevant conditions those
members in favor of the approval please
indicate those against
right that item is not approved
therefore I come back to accounts the
Steptoe thank you check i'm whether this
can be sent back to the applicant on the
defer basis to go away and have a closer
look at this I don't know whether that's
still possible I need a motion to be
moved at the moment the item is not
approved it has to be something okay
I'm unhappy with the commercial aspect
of the property I don't think enough
feasibility study has been carried out
in terms of looking at whether it is
actually viable to be actually been
rented out and I think it's over
development on the site that would be
proposal cancer Mountain
chairman thank you I think it's clear
that the majority of members of the
count of this committee are not in favor
of approving it as it stands I think
that there would have to be
consideration over any grounds for
refusal but I would I would consider
moving for deferment on the
understanding that the applicant the
applicant would consult with ward
members because clearly there is
something that is not satisfying members
of this committee and if it's possible I
would like to defer move for deferment
so the applicant can consult on the
understanding can the applicant will
consult with ward members on on a
suitable way forward yeah caster snap so
just before they check with regards to
counsel as well mountings suggestion or
motion there would be happy to accept
that I think it needs to be looked at in
a far greater detail where I've just
been informed instantly that there are
six other properties you know almost
adjacent to there that need to be looked
at in greater detail does not give the
clarity that's necessary we we need
precision here so I'll come back to
councilor mountain for a motion for
deferral with some clear motion for
deferment on the but before you move
ahead if we could just hear the advice
you're just knock your microphone on the
side chairman if I may yes I think there
needs to be some clear guidance on the
grounds given for a deferment and what
the applicant could
returned with if there is to be a
deferment yeah you have aperture okay
they go I would I'd move for deferment
on on the grounds of concerns of
development an inappropriate usage of
retail in in the town sorry over Oh
development and inappropriate usage of
retail outlets in in the location okay
we you you you do realize that on page I
point sixteen on seven point one for our
own economic development officer has
chosen to support this so I just wonder
so I've got to push you on this but to
be fair to the well money applicant my
understanding this does not meet the
area or action plan okay thank you
and so we've got not meeting the area
action plan with the overdevelopment
just a little bit more clarity on that
one
given that obviously we are actively
seeking elsewhere within the district to
provide accommodation of all classes
I it's a yeah the word here I think he's
appropriate accommodation thank you and
if I can just push you a little bit
further on the the approach towards
retail or housing at those bot on that
on that ground floor well I would I
would hope to get some feedback here
from offices if I may my understanding
is that it's inappropriate because of
the amount to it it upsets the the
street scene to have unoccupied retail
outlets where premises where there are
unoccupied retail premises currently
ranks thank you if I may to be clear the
pub is what we call a knife for use it's
not retail so what you're dealing with
is the change of use of a building that
is not in retail use is in commercial
use I get that but it's not in retail
use so you can't wrestle with the idea
of a loss of retail units that you've
not permitted them as retail units yet
so they haven't had a chance to be
retail and see how that goes
okay now that the point was raised
earlier on about not enough feasibility
and I don't know if this is weaving into
them what's been moved but uh our
officers being asked to ask what the
feasibility is of the shop units
proposed because they don't exist yet
the applicant has come forward offering
three small units to implement that
scheme and test the market and it might
be if it was implemented and they
weren't occupied yes I can see what's
coming that they that's weren't viable
but the applicant is saying give it give
it a chance or our officers being asked
as to what the feasibility of the pub
staying open if members could help us
with that chairman I'd be grateful
you're just not your Markov yeah
Thank You chairman my understanding is
the feasibility of well whether it is
appropriate if it's required in this
location because there are vacant units
we toast not about the change of use
it's the fact that is is it required
because they may end up sitting empty
and unoccupied as we we currently have
but I would just like to just ask you
all so at this point I've said I've said
quite a lot here in terms of the grounds
that and I I would say why I couldn't
vote in favor of this and I'd quite like
to open it to the floor if I made to see
if anyone else can any other members
because I've moved now to say yes and I
would like other members maybe to
address this we're just after clarity as
to what the other members are talking to
about that was right okay right
medication to step toe now let's take
check really what I was looking for with
from the applicants is that it's not
difficult to talk to local commercial
estate agents and various people to find
out what the the call for that type of
unit is within that town center location
I don't think it's a difficult thing to
have that sort of information to be
brought forward to us Thank You chairman
Rockford is it a very delicate situation
at the moment to my knowledge there are
at least six vacant commercial units in
in Rockford and very very close and I
know of two more that will very shortly
be closing so if it's a question of
change of use I don't think we need any
more commercial units thank you
okay but members
I didn't haven't noticed anyone second
in councilor mountain at this moment in
time that's coming from councilor
Steptoe okay
the only other note of caution to you is
is that economic viability it's not
necessarily a reason for refusal at this
point however you're choosing to put the
motion to defer at this point I think
the applicant has clearly heard the
nature of the discussion and and
anticipated your concerns so there is a
motion for deferment at this point
there's the if I were just sort of
praising your counsel amount in your
reasons for deferment is that you would
like some further evidence that retail
is appropriate in that location although
you do understand that's not necessarily
appropriate for a reason for refusal and
the the overdevelopment or the
appropriate appropriateness of the
intensity of that development yeah okay
okay
okay who's just ago okay those members
in favor of deferment and at this stage
please indicate those against that item
is now deferred item 72 is the same
application it's the listed building
consent I think in reality
I'll move from the chair that this item
is deferred to meet and run in
conjunction with the previous
application the members happy to support
that you please indicate thank you okay
a little bit cumbersome sorry for the
break in the middle the meeting closed
[Music]